eminem's daughter haley jade takes los
angeles as she celebrates valentine's
day with her boyfriend the 26 year old
documented the special day with her beau
evan first stop brunch at santa monica
hot spot elephante where the two enjoyed
drinks and a view next up haley and evan
dropped by a popular cantina then headed
for a night ferris wheel ride at the
santa monica pier where the two shared a
sweet kiss
but the couple didn't celebrate alone
haley and evan were joined by her older
sister elena who was there with her
fiance matt the sisters capped off their
day sharing these identical shots
kissing their boos with a beach side
view
haley and elena's double date follows
their dad's big performance during the
pepsi halftime show at the super bowl
where he took the stage alongside dr dre
snoop dogg mary j blige kendrick lamar
and surprise guests 50 cent and anderson
pack
[Music]
but before her dad's big moment haley
documented her excitement heading into
the stadium also sharing a full view of
the show's setup eminem then got the
crowd going with a special rendition of
his song lose yourself
[Music]
[Music]
and haley and elena were right there in
the stands witnessing their father make
history this halftime show marked the
first time that hip-hop took center
stage and it was a moment that rapper
buster rhymes told e.t made him
emotional you know
damn well
what this moment means not just for our
culture
obviously primarily what it means to our
culture is everything i was fortunate
enough to be able to come and witness
with one of the rehearsals
emotional for me
for tears
yeah because but
proud and tears of joy though like that
i'm able to actually live and witness
something so grand and so
superb and such a
phenomenal evolution for our culture and
for entertainment overall e.t also
chatted with halftime show executive
producer jesse collins about the impact
the musicians made after that
performance oh that it is everyone is in
tears because
you know that
you know dre
changed music
go back to nwa he made the world look at
the west coast and what they were saying
and then he has continued to change it
over and over again eminem 50 cent it
goes on and on kendrick snoop it's like
he keeps keeps changing music changing
music for the world one thing's for sure
haley and elena are proud daughters
[Applause]
[Music]